welcome back to new rockstars it's me mt
and captain america new world order is
the captain america movie we have all
been waiting for ever since we saw
america's new star-spangled man with a
plan swoop in and save the day in falcon
and the winter soldier it feels like
just yesterday i watched sam team up
with a senior citizen to beat up johnny
mayonnaise for his shield back good
times good times but with the title like
new world order i cannot help but wonder
who just who in the mcu will be needing
to get their butts kicked by our flying
uncle sam with a plan for trying to take
over the damn planet huh like who could
be behind phase five's new world order
well i think i may have an idea and it
has to do with a big easter egg marvel
put in age of ultron many moons ago so
come walk with me my nerd babies come
walk but before we go on this walk make
sure you head on over to new
rockstarsmerch.com so you can pick up
our newest latest obsession shirt we
have all sorts of amazing gear hats
shirts and all amazing nerd stuff for
you and your nerdy little loved ones so
head on over to new rockstarsmerch.com
today all right guys so what if i told
you that there's actually a hidden
organization of sketchy bad guys in the
mcu that are trying to make a new world
order huh and that that group has been
mcu canon for like a decade now and that
group could consist of the greatest evil
minds of the mcu like i don't know
doctor doom modok the leader and even
maybe a ulysses claw from the grave
would that blow your mind i'm sure you'd
think i was nuts that i was peddling
conspiracy theories that i heard on mark
zuckerberg's meta space or whatever it's
called these days but i believe it's
true and it's something that i hinted at
towards at the end of my recent video
that i did on how samuel stearns aka the
leader was going to factor into the new
she-hulk series that's right gang i'm
about to talk about the mcu
intelligencia a telegensia i'm going to
switch between the two pronunciations
multiple times most likely so whatever
the intelligencia the group of marvel's
smartest villains who come together to
try to take over the world with the
combined powers of their sinister
cerebrums and a group that was
established as mcu canon in avengers age
of ultron when the avengers are combing
through old shield hydrophiles to find
information on associates of the mad
genius known as baron strucker you know
that evil dude from hydra with the
monocle that gave wanda and pietro
powers the avengers pick up a file on
black panther's ulysses claw and
discover that on top of being a friend
to this hydra science freak strucker
claw also apparently used to be part of
mcu's intelligentsia as he is listed as
a former member marvel's intelligentsia
are actually a group in the comics that
originally came together to share evil
science ideas and do evil hood rat [ __ ]
together for example steel from the
impossible to break into nations of
wakanda and atlantis that's impressive
or create a bunch of gamma-powered
mutates using pretty much everyone bruce
banner knows as the intelligentsia are
directly responsible for the creation of
rick jones's a-bomb betty ross's red
she-hulk and thunderbolt ross's red hulk
hulk personalities and the villains that
actually comprise the intelligence in
the comics are hank pym's arch enemy
egghead modoc the leader the trapster
the mad thinker the red ghost and of
course doctor doom can't have a group of
smart people without doctor doom but
later on after doctor doom would betray
the team black panther villain ulysses
claw would be added to the roster but
the reason why i think the mcu
intelligencia will be behind captain
america new world order is specifically
because of a huge loose thread left
behind by the mcu since the end of the
incredible hulk the very man who would
form the intelligentsia himself in the
comics the leader because much like i
brought up in my recent video on the
leader after this nerd samuel stearns
got his brain mutated by hulk blood the
leader tells black widow that he has
used his new clairvoyance powers to
foresee an illustrious future defined by
power and influence a future that
apparently started the second his brain
started growing in calculating the
future with astonishing accuracy but
this is before black widow would shoot
him in the kneecaps and then shield
would arrest him and put him in
containment however since it was
revealed that shield was actually hydra
in captain america the winter soldier
the same movie that established hydra's
intense desire to try to predict the
future through their project insight
program and ant-man 1 revealed that
hydra was slowly rebuilding with you
know leaders like mitchell carson who
spent his entire shield career toppling
governments i can very much see the
leader being recruited by hydra formally
to continue project insight in secret
but this time with his own that's so
raven-ass six-head rather than zola's
algorithm so this being said and knowing
that the sketchy contessa valentina
allegra defontaine who already seems to
know that the future isn't going to need
a captain america anymore has strong
links to hydra in the comics as madame
hydra i have a strong feeling that she
will allow the leader to assemble the
greatest minds of the mcu to help her
manipulate american society by
predicting the future so that she can
eliminate threats to hydra's plans for a
new world order in secret rather than
using big-ass shield helicarriers that
literally are incapable of not crashing
into each other or the ground and i can
also see val naming samuel stearns the
leader of her group of the smartest bad
guys in the business a group that will
likely include modoc from quantum mania
a copy of the super smart zola the
highly anticipated doctor doom elias
starr aka egghead from ant-man and the
wasp who i don't think is dead at all
and i made a video about that in the
past and possibly even a resurrected
ulysses claw in his living sound form
like in the comics because in the comics
he doesn't really have a body he's
literally living sound so i think that
his death in black panther was sort of
setting up this new living sound form
and i also think it was implied in age
of ultron that baron strucker was
probably part of this intelligentsia
group as well before he died as he was
an insanely smart dude that had a
business relationship with claw who was
already part of that group there's not
really a lot of smarter people than
struck her it's a very small list i
believe that these villains led by the
leader will be the ones that sam wilson
will likely have to face off against in
captain america
new world order as the leader attempts
to reshape american society by helping
hydra pick the best influential world
figures to either eliminate or replace
with someone loyal to their agenda you
know a little bit like norman osborne
attempted to do during the dark rain
storyline after the events of secret
invasion slowly making the world more
villain friendly from the shadows a
world where marvel's most evil villains
can act without fearing the eye of the
law or the wrath of the avengers because
in this new world order there are no
avengers and the law is theirs to
control the leader was obsessed with the
idea of doing this exact thing when he
first popped up on the scene in the
comics as the incredible hulk's nemesis
so i would not be surprised if marvel
studios stayed true to the leader's
nature in the comics by making him the
leader of the mcu's intelligentsia for
captain america 4. because god knows the
leader is not going to appear as a
villain in a standalone hulk movie like
that is something that marvel studios
and universal pictures are allergic to
apparently come on just give us a hulk
movie just give us one really good world
war hall send that of space get them
angry and then have them come back with
a squad but anyways that is who i
believe is going to be the big major
threat for captain america new world
order but let us know what you think in
the comment section below my nerd babies
but anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me
mastertainment on twitter if you want to
see me tweet some weird [ __ ] and really
fun theories but more importantly you
can follow me rockstars wherever we are
on social media and also do not forget
to hit up new rockstarsmerch.com so you
can pick up our latest obsession shirts
and all of our amazing merch options
over there today but anyways thank you
guys so much for watching this video i
love you guys so much and i'll see you
guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you